now today we're going to talk about
doing intermittent fasting or some
serious weight loss there are many
magical and very cool things about
intermittent fasting that you need to be
aware of first of all it's extremely
cheap in fact it's free in fact you'll
save money
um it's easy and it doesn't require any
effort you're not doing something you're
just avoiding something you're avoiding
food fasting gives you a lot of extra
time so you're not constantly cooking
all day fasting will help you live
longer it makes you smarter because it
improves your cognitive function it
elevates your mood and lowers your risk
for many diseases so there are a lot of
benefits there are a couple drawbacks to
fasting number one you're going to lose
a lot of weight so that means you're
going to have to spend more money on
clothes so from that aspect it's going
to be more expensive and because you're
not cooking all day you're gonna have a
lot of extra time on your hands so
you're gonna have to find something to
do and because you're not spending all
this extra money on food you'll have a
lot of extra money that you have to
figure out what to do and that's a
problem but intermittent fasting is not
a diet it's a pattern of eating and not
eating it's putting you in the driver's
seat of when you tell your body it can
eat and when it needs to avoid eating I
mean if you think about it the worst
question to ask your body is
hmm what is my body in the mood for
today you're going to get an insane
answer in fact if I ask that question
right now I probably get the answer a
donut maybe some M Ms potato chips so
many times you'll get a very unhealthy
answer if you ask your body what it's in
the mood for this especially applies to
when your blood sugars are a problem
because if your blood sugars are too low
or too high you're going to get an
insane answer so it's kind of like you
being in the back seat of a car and
having some insane driver drive you
around this is not a good situation
because you're no longer in control and
unfortunately food has been controlling
you your entire life in fact our whole
existence revolves around food so doing
intermittent fasting starts to put you
in control over this Insanity which is a
very powerful thing for you personally
with your willpower with your
self-discipline and especially for your
health the one thing that you need to
know about intermittent fasting is that
every time you eat you trigger insulin
so insulin not only increases with sugar
and carbs but also from just eating in
general so the less frequent you eat the
less insulin you're going to trigger and
the more benefits you're going to have
our bodies have evolved over a very long
period of time
to not eating because long ago food
wasn't very available so our bodies have
adapted and developed all sorts of very
amazing genetics for surviving without
food and when I'm talking about survival
I'm talking about those genes that are
survival genes repair genes disease
genes turning off like for example
cancer turns off when you fast so all
sorts of fascinating survival things
related to your DNA get activated when
you start fasting so I'm going to show
you exactly how to apply this right now
okay so you take an average person who's
doing three meals with snacks in between
meals so they're doing three meals and
three snacks like six meals they're
getting a lot of spikes of insulin
through the day and their body is
suffering immensely from this
so the first thing to do is to stop
snacking that's step number one so then
you just have three meals a day and so
then you do that until you're
comfortable and then the next stage is
to
um skip your breakfast or that first
meal so in other words when you wake up
in the morning
because you're not snacking you're not
really going to be hungry especially if
you're doing keto but this video is not
necessarily on keto it's just about the
fasting pattern and how to get into this
on a nice gradual level so let the lack
of appetite in the morning dictate
whether you eat or not because the
underlying principle is don't eat unless
you're hungry so you wake up you're not
hungry don't eat go as long as you can
until your first meal okay so you work
up to your first meal being let's say at
noon right lunch time so let's say
you're eating at 12 and 6. that gives
you
18 hours of fasting okay you have this
window of eating which is six hours and
then you have 18 hours of fasting now to
add a little help to the situation if
you add more fat at the end of the meal
whether it's avocado
and Philemon nuts like macadamia nuts or
pecans or any type of fat that will
allow you to fast longer and get into
the next stages easier as a side note
there's a lot of other things we can do
to improve this situation especially
with blood sugars as well for example if
you eat a big salad as the first thing
that you eat in your meal and you put
olive oil dressing on an extra virgin
olive oil and you put some balsamic
vinaigrette or even apple cider vinegar
on that salad you're gonna create a
really cool effect with your blood
sugars okay number one you're eating a
lot of fiber fiber buffers insulin fiber
is the only carbohydrate that won't
trigger insulin the oil in the extra
virgin olive oil is also another thing
that really won't trigger insulin that
much if at all and the oil helps you
extract some of the fat soluble
nutrients from that salad and I'm
talking about like the phytonutrients
which are about soluble so you get the
benefit of that vinegar whether you do
apple cider vinegar or balsamic
vinaigrette gives you a very potent
anti-diabetic effect because it helps
you lower blood sugars as well as
insulin and this is why I recommend the
outside of vinegar like a tablespoon and
some water a few times a day that alone
will greatly help you and then if you
add some cinnamon to your diet like
whether it's in that drink or in
something else cinnamon is another
potent thing to help your blood sugars
and then of course vitamin D is another
thing you can add to this mix and just
get more sun that will help you okay so
you're at this stage you're eating two
meals a day right six hour window now
ideally you wouldn't want a snack within
that window but if you had to that would
be the time to snack not in the fasting
window because we want that 18 hours of
just pure fasting so you're going to do
this for a period of time until you get
comfortable okay as you get used to it
then you want to take it to the next
step especially if you want to lose more
weight okay what we want to do is we
want to take those two meals and get
them closer together like within a four
hour period so let's say for example you
get up in the morning you fast all the
way to noon you're still not hungry you
keep going and then you fast until two
o'clock you have your first meal and
your second meal at six so now we have a
four hour eating window and a 20 hour
fasting window which is going to be even
better and you're going to see more fat
loss so you're going to do that for a
couple weeks until you feel comfortable
and then the next phase and this is the
icing and the cake I'm sorry I don't
want to tempt you okay
but this is called omad one meal a day
so now what's happening is we collapse
these two meals together as one one
large meal make sure it's nutrient dense
and it's healthy and that's all you're
gonna eat now of course you're not going
to be able to eat the same calories as
you would when you're doing two meals
but the benefit of this is not really
that you lowered your calories it's the
fact that you're fasting for 23 hours
okay that's going to produce even
greater benefits for your immune system
for your brain for your anti-aging for
your repair now recently I kind of
stumbled on something that is a another
tweak to this omad plan okay that you
might want to consider it's just a
slight change that could make a big
difference with your sleep and even
greater Improvement in your blood sugars
and insulin and insulin resistance okay
and that would be have that last meal no
later than 3 P.M so it's it's midday
because
the later that you eat apparently that
can interfere with your sleep cycles and
that can stir up certain genes that are
related to food and that can inhibit
your sleep so you might want to just try
this eat a little bit sooner make sure
it's a big meal right in the middle of
the day like maybe two or three
and see if you don't sleep a lot better
I'm doing that right now and I'm finding
I'm sleeping much better which is then
going to help you lose even more weight
because the better the sleep you have
the less cortisol the more growth
hormone the more fat burning the more
benefits with a lot of things like your
energy will be improved now there's a
lot of other things we can do to improve
your results like we can add exercise
we can also add the healthy version of
the ketogenic diet which I promote which
just is higher quality ingredients and
more nutrients in that meal so there's
many things you can add to this mix
now the last phase of fasting is really
interjecting some periodic prolonged
fasting episodes so you can add in like
once a week or once every two weeks a 48
hour fast or even a 72 hour pass it's a
three day or even a 120 hour fast which
is a five day fast which could be
unbelievable for your immune system and
especially if you wanted to prevent
cancer because as soon as you start
fasting for long periods of time you are
literally destroying cancer in your body
so I just wanted to give you the bird's
eye view of how intermittent fasting can
be started at the very beginning and
gradually improving your fasting to the
point where you're really doing it for
some serious weight loss and health
benefits so it'd be really the only
thing to do now is to just start don't
think about it don't wait for the
medical profession to finally agree that
this is the best thing for your health
because that's not going to happen it's
only when you yourself try this and you
know the power of intermittent fasting
and what it can do for your health this
is the thing the solution that you have
been searching for and you'll see when
you try this so just get started with it
and all you need to know next is what to
eat and I have a couple of videos on
this playlist starting with video one
like here check it out